they just announced a Disney Plus like
everybody's super excited it's the one
new streaming service that people are
actually excited about because they're
doing Hulu and Disney and ESPN it's like
twelve bucks or something like that but
they're doing a Sandlot series yeah and
they got all you guys back except Benny
except Mike yeah he's not gonna do it
he said he not want to I was a
firefighter the jerk you know the world
yeah Sandlot fans were still it would be
like they're still pissed there's not
enough that he's a firefighter yeah
exactly the dog back as well the dog is
the dog past so what have you guys
filmed the Sandlot series for the Disney
Plus not yet they they kind of just
announced it last year you know we all
went into met with them they told us
some of the storylines and stuff we were
interested what is the concept behind it
you guys have kids that are doing it or
what's the yeah I think generally that's
the idea and I think the Sam Lots
involved in it and I you know what they
kind of explained
I won't I don't think I can probably say
too much you know hoping I still can be
in it you know thanks I think it has
ties to that and you know all the guys
are into doing it and the the kind of
concepts they had were fun and I have a
lot of stuff with the squints character
which is cool cause chanson Mason who
plays quince is the guy that I've sort
of still hung out with over the year he
was great in the logic video the logic
M&M video yeah unbelievable and I had
him on the podcast and we talked about
it a lot of people were wondering if it
was him or logic cuz he did so good that
was him the whole video one more Jim and
Sam catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM Adam